poles will open in turkey as a
presidential runoff within the next two
hours voters will choose between
President
an opposition leader Kamal Khalid in
Ankara Russell Cedar looks at what the
candidates had to say during their last
pitch to voters
as campaigning due to a close the
presidential candidates made their final
push to convince Waters
erdogan ended his campaign in Istanbul
where his political carrier began
stability and continuity have been the
key word throughout his election
campaign
he has promised his support is a
powerful and prosperous country with a
more assertive role in the international
Arena
this is turkey Century we want to make
this year's Centennial a beginning for a
stronger Nation based on the solid
foundations we have been building for
our nation for the past 21 years
[Music]
but he is now facing his most difficult
challenge his rival Kemal kalistarova a
former accountant backed by a broad
opposition forced erdogan into a second
round runoff a rare setback for erdogan
after winning several elections over the
last two decades crystal says the vote
in the runoff is a referendum on the
future direction of Turkey
for your rights for justice and the rule
of law there needs to be prosperity in
every household my aim is to bring
Justice to this country and peace in
every household I want you to be sure of
that
since assuming the office as the leader
of the people's Republican party
khalistorro has lost several elections
against erdogan but determined to defeat
erdogan six opposition parties have
joined forces for this presidential
election with kalistarily chosen as
their Unity leader but erdogan led in
the first round with 49.5 percent of the
world while cholesterol received 44.9
percent neither president erdogan nor
the opposition leader colostrum could
secure enough votes to win in the first
round that result was by many but the
main surprise was the highway for the
Nationalist parties many now believe
they could be the king makers in the
runoff and that has forced the
presidential candidates to reconsider
the election campaign
to attract the Nationalist Woods the
mild-man and opposition leader
kalistarlo focuses his second round
campaign on the anti-refugee sentiments
promising to send home millions of
Syrian Afghan and Pakistani refugees
syrians will go was one of the main
slogans written on billboards
as a result the leader of the
ultra-nationalist victory party
umitosda has announced his support for
kalistarova
but sinanogan another ultra-nationalist
presidential candidate who came third in
the first round has decided to support
president erdogan in the runoff
preliminary results will be announced
hours after voters cast their ballots
turkey will either continue with
president erdogan or choose a new leader
but this election will be closely washed
especially by refugees grappling with
fear and uncertainty rasu Sardar Al
Jazeera Ankara
is also in the capital Ankara and says a
runoff is Uncharted Territory for
Turkish voters
this is the first time that they're
going to a runoff to decide who is going
to be their president and this explains
the anxiety but the uncertainty about
what's next now people are divided
across political lines you have the
supporters of the opposition basically
saying that they are determined to vote
for their candidate
because they say this is someone who is
able to fix the economy to bring more
political uh reforms and also restore
what they say is a genuine Democratic
institutions in the country on the other
hand you have supporters of President
saying that they're going to vote for
him to honor his legacy and also because
he is the candidate for stability and
further modernizing turkey and as that
continues as that divide continues
coupled with the sense this is going to
be also a tight race getting loads of
expectations more uncertainty but people
are saying it is a defining moment for
for turkey